the problem with the way that slavery is
taught in school today is not that it is
taught or that too much is said on the
subject but rather that the lessons are
intentionally narrow so as to give the
laughably false impression that slavery
was a sin unique to white westerners
kids should be taught the truth that
slavery was you know a ubiquitous
institution across the entire Globe from
Millennia that Africans kidnapped and
sold each other into slavery that white
Europeans were captured and sold into
slavery themselves by Arab slave Traders
for centuries that Western Powers
abolished slavery and the slave trade
long before much of the rest of the
world did Etc all of this should be
taught but leftists are the ones who
don't want any of that mention they are
the ones trying to censor the slavery
conversation in schools as usual they
are guilty of the sin that they are
accusing others of committing